Trascrizione: Eleonora Fantinel
Revisore: Giorgia Borsellino
Buonasera a tutti.
Qualche tempo fa ho preso
un Frecciarossa, e mentre viaggiava
ho guardato lo schermo che segnava
la velocità di 230 chilometri all’ora
e mi è venuto da sorridere perché con gli
sci sono andata più veloce di quel treno.
Molti mi chiedono
quante ore mi sono dovuta allenare
per arrivare a quelle velocità.
La risposta è che, oltre all’allenamento
e alla preparazione di anni,
sono state necessarie anche
tutta una serie di condizioni favorevoli.
Per me è stato come mettere insieme
tutti i pezzi di un puzzle.
Nel 2014 ho debuttato nella
categoria massima, in S1.
E usavo questo casco.
(Applausi)
Le prime gare le ho vinte,
andavo anche abbastanza forte
però il casco non mi dava molta fiducia,
lo sentivo un po’ troppo grosso
e soprattutto quando cercavo di frenare
mi sembrava di decollare.
Così ho pensato che avrei potuto trovare
qualcosa di un po’ più aerodinamico,
fatto un po’ meglio per me,
su misura per me.
Così durante l’estate me ne sono fatta
fare uno nuovo, un po’ più compatto.
Nel 2015 avevo il mio nuovo casco
ed è stata una stagione pazzesca perché
ho vinto la mia prima Coppa del Mondo
e i campionati mondiali.
Però-
(Applausi)
Però quando ci siamo trovati
sulla pista più veloce al mondo
le condizioni non erano favorevoli perché
faceva molto caldo e c’era poca neve.
E così ho concluso la mia stagione
con soli 231 chilometri all'ora.
Molti di voi penseranno
che è già una velocità folle
ma non per me,
per chi pratica questo sport
e punta ogni volta a superare i limiti.
La possibilità di fare meglio
c’è stata l’anno seguente,
quando ormai avevo trovato
il giusto assetto con i miei materiali
e sono riuscita a vincere
la mia seconda Coppa del Mondo consecutiva
ma rimanevano comunque due problemi:
la pista dove erano stati stabiliti
tutti i record fino a quel momento
ormai non c’era più
e la pista diversa era un’incognita perché
la velocità più alta segnata da una donna
era di soli 236 chilometri all’ora,
ben distante dal record del mondo.
Quando facciamo quel tipo di competizioni,
le gare per il tentativo di record,
siamo in pochi al mondo, solo
una selezione può partecipare,
i più forti. Sappiamo quando iniziano ma
in realtà non sappiamo quando finirà
e soprattutto se ci sarà la possibilità di
partire dalla cima e tentare il record.
Per darvi il senso dell’incognita,
un giorno siamo partiti
circa una ventina di metri sotto la cima,
ma di notte aveva fatto vento
e così in pista c’erano delle onde create
dal vento di neve ventata.
Dalla partenza non si riusciva a capire
quanto avrebbero potuto dare fastidio.
Però me ne sono accorta subito scendendo,
perché ho iniziato a muovermi,
gli sci sbattevano
e mi sentivo come in una centrifuga.
Ho provato a fermare
quei movimenti, ma non riuscivo
e ho iniziato ad avere paura di cadere.
Così ho pensato di provare ad aprirmi
dalla posizione aerodinamica, per cercare
di rallentare un po’ e sono riuscita
a rimanere in piedi per fortuna.
Ecco questo è il video di quella discesa.
Forse a voi non sarà sembrato così tragico
come l’ho descritto io
ma vi assicuro che a quella velocità
trovarsi lì è stato abbastanza scioccante.
Due giorni dopo saremmo partiti
pochi metri sotto la cima e
sapevamo benissimo che sarebbe stato
il grande giorno, il giorno dei record
ma io ero ancora spaventata
dall’ultima discesa fatta e soprattutto
avevo ancora la convinzione che
solo gli uomini avrebbero potuto batterlo
perché loro erano più vicini
alla velocità dei record.
Come tutte le sere
ho finito di fare gli sci,
ho preparato i miei vestiti portafortuna
e sono andata a dormire.
Io sogno molto, e a volte
sono sogni premonitori
e quella notte ho sognato
di fare il record.
Al mattino ha spento la sveglia e subito
mi è tornato in mente il sogno.
Così sono corsa alla finestra per
vedere le condizioni del meteo.
Era una giornata stupenda
e ho subito pensato
che se fosse dovuto succedere
quello sarebbe stato il giorno perfetto.
Per scaramanzia non ho detto
niente a nessuno del sogno
e mentre salivo in seggiovia,
il mio allenatore mi spiegava che
purtroppo avevo rischiato di cadere
perché sono molto leggera.
E questo per me sarebbe stato un limite.
Ma mentre lui parlava,
io continuavo a pensare al sogno
e sorridevo senza dire nulla.
Il primo giro, pochi metri sotto la cima,
ho deciso di farlo con calma,
di essere prudente per valutare
le condizioni della pista
ma nonostante questo sono riuscita
ad andare a 240 chilometri all’ora,
battendo così il record italiano.
Quello per me era già l’obiettivo,
però a quel punto non mi bastava più.
Sentivo che avrei potuto battere
il record del mondo.
In quel momento ero felicissima
perché avevo raggiunto il mio obiettivo
e stava iniziando a realizzare che
avrei potuto battere il record del mondo.
Però non avevo tenuto conto
di un particolare:
come secondo paio di sci avevo preparato
quello veloce ma instabile
di quando avevo rischiato di cadere.
E così ho iniziato a pensare
se utilizzare quello già sciolinato
e cerato, ma che non mi dava fiducia
o preparare di nuovo
quello appena utilizzato,
cosa che però in genere
non si fa molto spesso
perché potrebbe esserci la possibilità che
non sia più veloce come il giro precedente
Negli ultimi istanti
che avevo a disposizione,
ho deciso di seguire il mio istinto.
Per quell’ultima discesa
avevo scelto tutto ciò che mi faceva
star bene, che mi dava fiducia:
i guanti, gli sci e il casco,
proprio come nel sogno.
Ero in partenza con il sorriso
perché sapevo che ormai
non avevo più niente da perdere.
O forse qualcosa da guadagnare.
Mi sono detta: “o la va o la spacca”.
Ho messo il casco, ho fatto un bel respiro
ho contato fino al tre e via.
Sono iniziati così i 20 secondi
più lunghi della mia vita.
Subito dovevo pensare a mettermi
velocemente in posizione aerodinamica.
Dovevo ricordarmi della compressione
nel finale ma soprattutto pensavo,
mentre scendevo, “ma quanto manca?”
Erano secondi interminabili.
Appena superata la linea di fine pista,
ho pensato di non aver battuto il record
perché avevo fatto meno fatica
rispetto al giro precedente.
Ma un po’ di speranze ce l’avevo comunque.
Quindi mentre frenavo, cercavo di guardare
oltre la rete per capire qualcosa in più
finché all’ultima curva
ho visto la folla esplodere.
Avevo battuto il record del mondo,
avevo fatto 247 chilometri all’ora,
ero la donna
più veloce al mondo.
(Applausi)
Fare un record del mondo per noi
è il massimo obiettivo che si possa avere,
però una volta raggiunto
non mi bastava più di nuovo.
Volevo cercare di andare sempre più veloce
però quando raggiungi l’apice,
e non hai più nessuno davanti,
non hai punti di riferimento
e quindi non puoi
copiare nessuno.
Così ho pensato che l’unico modo che
avevo a disposizione,
per cercare di andare più veloce era
quello di inventare e studiare cose nuove.
Così sono stata in galleria del vento e
mi sono fatta aiutare da alcuni ingegneri
per fare degli studi sulla aerodinamica.
E siamo anche arrivati a brevettare
un nuovo casco, studiato apposta su di me,
sulla mia posizione aerodinamica.
Però anche in quel caso
non avevo tenuto conto di un particolare,
che prima di tutto bisognerebbe riuscire
ad avere un buon feeling
con i propri materiali, perché anche
se sono i più veloci e aerodinamici
non è scontato che si riescano
ad utilizzare in maniera efficiente.
Da lì ho iniziato a fare una serie
di cambiamenti che mi hanno portata
ad essere sempre più insicura e instabile
sia a livello tecnico che mentale.
Finché a un certo punto
ho preso una decisione radicale:
resettare tutto e tornare al giorno
dei record, con gli stessi materiali
che mi hanno fatto diventare
la donna più veloce al mondo.
Ho deciso di tornare al punto zero per
cercare di crescere di nuovo
e magari sognare di nuovo.
Sono Valentina Gareggio e ho capito
che quel record era nato dentro di me
prima ancora di diventare realtà.
(Applausi)